i think people who don't manage their
time
well fail as leaders whether at a
fortune 500 company
or at a brand new startup
[Music]
raymond stern thank you so much for
being on the show 20 minute leaders i
really appreciate it
my pleasure great to be here this is
going to be so much fun you know i'm not
going to be able to
do justice for the insane amount of
things that you've done but
just as a brief intro you've you did
stanford for your undergrad
very proud of that and then the harvard
mba moved on to consulting
senior vice president positions at
intuit and yahoo
venture capital very successful venture
capital and clear path over the past
several years but you've also done the
entrepreneurial journey yourself which
i'd love to hear more about raymond
there's so many things i want to ask you
i want to talk about leadership i want
to talk about scaling about
team building but can you give me a
little bit of a brief
intro about who you are and what excites
you
um yeah you know a lot of things excite
me but i love
i guess first and foremost i love
helping entrepreneurs when i think about
my own career the thing that i
i got the biggest kick out of was
helping
coach and mentor people whether it was a
bcg
uh when i was a partner there and
actually before i was a partner there or
where there was a
yahoo or intuit and certainly in the
work i do today with entrepreneurs and
so
that's where i get my biggest kick and
the thing that gives me the biggest
amount of pride when i meet with people
uh over time many years later is to see
the great things they've gone on to do
because they're amazingly capable and
feeling like maybe i had one
tiny tiny little aspect of that in
helping them along the way
so so you know looking at these various
experiences from an entrepreneur
consultant
and and then venture capital where do
you
where are you most attracted to if you
had to choose of these three fields
um so let me just clarify venture
capital i don't do a lot of venture
capital my work is
mainly helping entrepreneurs uh with my
time and every so often i invest but
just i just wanted to clarify that for
your audience
but where i get you know where i really
get my kick is working with the
entrepreneurs that's you know i loved my
experiences at
bcg and in intuit and at yahoo but
um i really really enjoy the startup
environment much more and
for one main reason one because you can
just get stuff done
and the piece of which these these uh
these organizations move is
radically different than what you can do
at an intuitive yahoo or any larger
company now i think there's a lot to
learn from those larger companies
especially as you're trying to scale a
business
and hopefully that's part of what i
bring to the clients that i work with so
right okay so how many entrepreneurs
would you say you've got to work with or
or lend a hand over these past
you know several decades um probably
25 or 30 where i've really worked with
them pretty intimately and you know at
this point in time right now i'm working
probably actively with about
10 or 12. wow and you know the
the great thing is when i work with
entrepreneurs it tends to be on a on a
long-term basis i mean these are
relationships that i've built over time
and i get to see them from
the early early days um to you know
companies that are selling for billions
of dollars
and have gone on to do some pretty
incredible things so it's a long-term
relationship
and i really enjoy watching that
evolution
and the amazing things they do with
their teams to build great companies
incredible okay let's start with your
executive positions within intuit and
yahoo senior vice president
you're basically you're you're there
you're helping lead these billion dollar
businesses
and and lead strategy what does that
even entail
what is the role of a senior vice
president and these two incredible
companies and what are you know some of
the
the key takeaways that you would take
from those times
um you know each each role is different
and that there's you know it depends on
the function you're leading so i had the
great opportunity to lead
you know as you mentioned some strategy
departments but i also got to lead
a marketing organization when i was at
yahoo i led the small business i'm sorry
i didn't do it i led the small business
division when i was at yahoo
had the opportunity to lead some of our
operations internationally
so it's a pretty diverse set of things
and obviously you've got to have some
expertise in the area
leading but the thing that's common with
every single one of them
is you gotta lead i mean at the end of
the day when you're at that level in an
organization
your role is primarily getting the right
people uh
in the organization and getting them
aligned on the critical priorities for
the
organization and then ensuring that
you're you're
making progress against those priorities
and if you're not putting in place
processes to course correct and get back
on track and things like that
but ultimately my the common thing is
one of
of leadership um assuming you have some
reasonable amount of domain expertise
because at that level you're not
you can't roll up your sleeves and do
everything right i mean the
organizations are complex and there's a
lot going on
which is very different than when you're
an early stage entrepreneur
where you're rolling up your sleeves and
doing everything and one of the
challenges entrepreneurs face
as they scale and grow their
organizations is making that transition
from i do everything to a higher grade
people
and now i've got to make sure that they
do great work and how to facilitate and
enable that
in a way that's that's powerful so i'm
gonna ask a weird question what what are
some of the worst
things that a person at the level of a
senior vice president a big company can
do
in terms of leadership you know what are
some of the don'ts that because you know
a lot of the times
people and i i ask what what should i
keep in mind at what should i do as a
leader i want to know what i shouldn't
do
what are some things that i i don't
realize that i might do
and i want to avoid them you know
purposefully yeah sure and and actually
the flip side of it is what makes them
great so
i'm going to give it a negative but just
turn it around and you'll understand the
good part
i think oftentimes leaders
don't get clarity on what they're
solving for and that's
you know they need to understand what
are the critical levers that they're
responsible for that are going to drive
whatever outcomes they need to drive to
support the success of the company
that's one thing so if you don't do that
you're kind of screwed because you're
going to go off and do stuff in the
wrong direction
the second thing that that leaders don't
do
as well as they should sometimes is
make sure that everyone is aligned on
that because you might know what you're
doing but if you don't get the entire
organization aligned on the same things
you're going to get
people going in disparate directions and
at the end of the day you won't get to
the end result that you're looking for
and you know there's a whole list of
things but i think the one that
most leaders um
fail to appreciate how how powerful it
can be if they get it right is how they
allocate their time
because if you think about it learning
you know if you want to impact
outcomes um you can learn new skills but
that can take years or weeks or months
whereas you can decide in in a heartbeat
i'm going to stop
doing this and start doing this and then
you'll have a better impact on those
things
and that was an early lesson i had
working for a great leader who came out
of ge a guy named steve bennett who i
worked for for many years when i was at
intuit
and i just found that to be incredibly
powerful and i think people who don't
manage their time well fail as leaders
whether at a
fortune 500 company or a brand new
startup
the most critical thing you need to
think about is where am i going to spend
my time because that's the most precious
commodity
you have and at a fortune 500 company
you're generally not worried about
having enough money
whereas the most precious commodity a
startup has is just making sure they
have enough oxygen
definitely i haven't i had a fascinating
conversation with the ceo of super tools
a productivity company in israel
and he's now developing a new type of
calendar where the thinking of taking
ownership over your time slots through
time blocking
and and different best practices and one
of the things we're talking about is how
you know we
it very easily can become slaves of our
own calendars and and
instead of the calendar working for us
we work for our calendar and chasing our
own tale
i i'm you know i see that for with
myself all the time
so what can you do though as an
executive because you have everybody
wants to meet your calendar
full you know from like weeks in advance
so how do you take ownership
over over your time how do you actually
sit back and re and
think properly what are the priorities
that you should be focused on
so i mean i think it ties to the word
you just said which is one of the
priorities you want to allocate your
time to those so
this is not whoever wants my time can i
have my time right you want to invest
your time and areas and that's different
than saying
i'm going to be accessible and make time
for people to find me if they need to
but you structure that you don't make
that on demand whenever you want
and you know i believe strongly that
making time to engage with the broader
set of employees in the organization is
important and certainly with your direct
reports in the next level down
so you want to explicitly make time for
that so that's one of the critical
priorities is spending time with your
direct reports as an example
but it really is about being really
rigorous on
investing your time in those areas so
one is just know what your priorities
are and for sure do it
the second is you know we we tend to be
creatures of you know what my calendar
says so if it says i have a one hour
meeting i'm gonna have a one hour
meeting and the reality is if i'm done
in 30 minutes i'm i'm done with the
meeting and i
i find that i create all sorts of
pockets of time throughout my day
and i used to do this as an executive
because i never went back to back to
back
i would end things early just because my
calendar said it was an hour
didn't mean i was going to talk so
you're actually to fight parkinson's law
right
yeah the other thing you need to do is
make sure that the people you're meeting
with
are being respectful of your time so for
example you know
i don't like having meandering meetings
um just on random subjects when i have a
one-on-one it's like it's focused on the
critical priorities how are we doing
against them how can i help what are we
doing to get back on track and
opportunities to give people feedback
etc and it doesn't mean you don't allow
some time for
chit chat and bs and how you're doing
and things like that because that's
important it's an important
part of a relationship and i also just
love doing that as a as a human being
but it does mean that you you expect of
others to be disciplined about the
conversations they're having and then
the way i do that is just encourage
everyone and i talk a lot with
entrepreneurs about this when you're
having one-on-ones with people
make sure there's a specific agenda this
isn't like what do you feel like talking
about today
and in general that agenda should be
tied to what are the most important
priorities that they're working on to
deliver results for the business i had
one of the most
incredible leaders in in my unit in 8200
that
he would not be willing to meet with
anybody unless they sent him an agenda
ahead of time and it had to be in a
proper format
as a part of the calendar invite and
that was because he was just working you
know
8 a.m to 8 p.m non-stop back-to-back
meetings and he had to choose
which ones are most important but
raymond the most important question of
the interview so far
what what is this background behind you
which beach are we at oh well
should i let you guess you ought to know
given where you come from i'm going to
guess
tell baruch beach but i might be wrong
it's banana it's banana beach okay well
i'm from tabaru so this is
well and you know i was there last
summer uh having a great visit with
family and also doing a little bit of
work with some of my clients
and you know i put it up this june since
we couldn't travel to israel and i just
wanted to be reminded of how wonderful
this summer it was there
and you can probably tell from the
plastic chairs and the you know plastic
bags with all the junk in it
it definitely yeah no no and but really
the sunset gives it all because there's
nothing like the tel aviv sunset
i agree but we're getting way off topic
raymond
talk to me a little bit about scale what
what what are
some of the key challenges that that
entrepreneurs face as they get to a
point where they're able to scale their
to scale their business upwards and you
know i'm talking i was a young
entrepreneur myself that
i i didn't have yet the privilege of
getting to that position but i can't
wait to get there
and when i do get there i want to keep
these things in mind right so
you know what makes them in my
experience what makes an entrepreneur
incredibly successful uh are the things
that can kill them down the road if they
don't adapt and so what do i mean by
that you know in the early days as you
know and you've talked to many
entrepreneurs and know many of them
you kind of uh you you have to do
everything yourself
and by definition you're a micromanager
you're doing everything yourself
um and so that's one aspect and you know
processes
you know even if you're 10 people you
pull them together you get in a room you
talk you leave right it's pretty simple
but as complexity goes up those
processes break down and so you need to
think about what are some processes to
drive alignment to know how we're doing
and that's when companies start putting
in place okr
processes and again you need to do it
intelligently not overkill and stifle an
organization
so processes is something you need to
think about
how you use your own time right if you
hire
awesome people who are world class when
you're scaling and growing and have the
luxury to hire them because in the early
days you can't hire them
uh you can't afford them and you don't
need them and so but when you hire them
the mistake i see entrepreneurs
sometimes make is they still manage them
the way they were micromanaging when
they had four people in the company
and the reality is if you do that you'll
just piss off a bunch of great people
and they'll leave
and so you won't be able to scale
because you won't get the talent that
you need to build an organization so for
me it comes down
primarily to you know how you lead and
manage
in terms of the role you play
by enabling others versus doing it all
yourself and making sure you learn to
let go
obviously you've got to trust those
individuals and they you need to
develop that trust um and then secondly
putting in place processes for
sort of broader management of the
company whether it's staff meetings
alignment processes okr processes
because the processes you used early in
the early days
just don't scale when you get past 30 or
40 people and certainly when you get
into the hundreds they just don't last
doesn't mean you can't keep some of the
cultural aspects and
special companies do doesn't mean you
can can't keep some
elements of those things like all hands
meetings every friday or things like
that
but even that eventually breaks down
when you're multiple geographies and
people are sleeping during
all hands meeting something so but but
then you know as a
as young entrepreneurs first-time
entrepreneurs going through this journey
first time you hit employee number 31
how do you even know what to do i mean
it's not like there's a textbook that
you can just go to and say okay
these are this is how you now can can go
and
and these are the processes you should
keep these are the processes you
shouldn't
maybe an mba is maybe that they have
some relevant classes but
how do entrepreneurs get this
information i mean i think most of it
comes from
just talking to people who are
experienced right i mean and then
in a large part that's the role i play
but many others do they're advisors
they're experienced people who can help
you do it and i think the critical thing
is not to do it when you hit employee 31
but to anticipate and do it so that you
are there when you hit employee 31
and you don't all of a sudden wake up
and go oh it's not working
right and so anticipating those critical
milestones and they're not as hardwired
as 30 or 40 or 50.
it's more just thinking about okay we've
been working where everyone's in a room
and we can talk about priorities and now
we not
need to start thinking about more formal
processes and so what do those look like
and maybe it's something like okrs or
some other approach to setting
priorities
maybe it's staff meetings on you know as
opposed to informal staff meetings
at some point building in more formality
and what i mean by that is
going through the critical priorities
are we red yellow green on these talking
about what we're doing with the red ones
talking about as a team how are we going
to improve them
as opposed to a stand-up where we just
go around the room and talk about
whatever we think we want to talk about
definitely and so again it's the
anticipation
and putting them in place so that you
don't get you know what ends up
happening is some companies wait too
long and then they grind to a halt
because what ends up happening is the
complexity kills them you know all of a
sudden
you can't know everything that's going
on you can't keep an organization
completely aligned when it's 50 60 70 or
100 people
i love it okay so i'm taking priorities
from leadership as an executive
i'm taking a anticipation as as
entrepreneurs you scale up let's talk
about teams what what are
some of you know your insights seeing
dozens of entrepreneurs successful and
unsuccessful
what makes a really really good team not
just a founding team but but you know a
good
a good solid team that is able to take a
business
prove it and start scaling it upwards
yeah i think
you know there are a bunch of things
that that make teams great
and um you know i've i've learned a lot
of this from some of the great leaders
that i've had the opportunity to work
for right
um and so let me just give you some
ideas these are not in any particular
order they're all
important but you know a great team
you know gets back to priorities they
know what they're solving for
right and if you randomly grabbed anyone
from that team and said what are the
five most important priorities for the
company they ought to be able to answer
that
consistently and if they don't there's a
disconnect so right teams are really
aligned on that
um they're not important on when the
company is huge let's say 200 people
i think you know certainly an executive
team needs to do it i would like for
everyone but if
people sitting around the table aren't
solving for the same thing
you've got a problem sitting around the
executive table if someone further down
the organization doesn't remember all of
that but they know what they work on
right and they know ideally they know
how it supports what the company's
uh priorities are um you know so yeah i
think this notion
of everyone knows what the critical
priorities are for the organization
you know but there are a bunch of other
aspects to that i kind of alluded to it
a second ago this alignment piece you
want to make sure that
everyone in the organization is aligned
and supporting those
objectives if you don't want people
working on stuff that
doesn't fit because one they're not
going to feel good about working on
stuff that doesn't matter
secondly it's a waste of resources
you're not going to be efficient and
optimal in terms of how you use your
limited capacity
you know other things great teams do
really well is
um they can balance long term and short
term you know it's really easy to solve
for the near term thing
um and it's really easy to solve for the
long term
the hard thing is to balance those and
you need to balance because you've got
to deliver for today but you also have
to
deliver in the future when the products
of today aren't the most critical ones
or they you've got to evolve those
products you got to think about new
opportunities
so that's another one that great teams
really do they balance those and it's a
tough thing because
you're always going to be pushed to put
the resources on the things that deliver
today and that's the classic innovators
dilemma right people who don't invest in
the future
and i've seen companies get really
screwed by that um
over time the other thing to think about
is
that i think great teams do is they're
clear on who owns decisions
and there's a big difference between
having input and owning a decision great
teams want the best input
um but this isn't a consensus-led vote
you want to be clear on who owns the
decision and ultimately a ceo
owns the all decisions but you want to
be clear on who owns those so that you
can have
you know if you if you aren't clear then
the organizations are confused or
someone makes a decision and someone
overrides a decision and so you want to
make sure that
everyone's clear on the dec on who owns
the decision but at the same time allow
for the great input because you want the
best thinking
brought brought to bear um yeah
i could go on with the whole list of
things so if you want to keep going or
pick some other topic
this is just this is just gold and i
can't believe 20 minutes are almost up
i'm shocked every single time and every
time i think to myself
i should have called this show 30 minute
leaders not 20 minute leaders i don't
know why i cut myself short of 10
minutes of pure knowledge
but raymond before we leave i i want to
ask for one
key advice that you would give me as a
young entrepreneur
soon starting my entrepreneurial journey
hopefully sooner rather than later with
my own venture
what what is probably the number one or
the number or the two
top things that i should be keeping in
mind as i go on this crazy path
so i think the number one thing is make
sure you really believe
in what you're doing because inevitably
uh i mean this is you've heard this a
million times you know
every at every corner there's going to
be a barrier
it's hard to raise money and even the
successful entrepreneurs will tell you
at some point it was hard
you're going to have challenges in doing
what you need to do in terms of
launching the product or building
product
people are going to tell you no you're
going to struggle getting distribution
deals or whatever it is you're trying to
do to build your business
you're going to lose great people and
you're going to feel it's the end of the
world because i just lost my vp of
engineering
and so you're going to continually be
facing these roadblocks and it's really
really hard
so you better make sure you really
believe in it and want to do it
and that you're not doing it just
because hey this is a quick may to make
a buck and i'm not saying you're doing
that at all
but there are you know sometimes i meet
entrepreneurs that i
i don't really get that they
truly truly believe in it and i don't
mean in the
hey i want to change the world but
they're passionate about what they do
and they're willing to go through all
the battles and i think that's the most
important
the second thing i would say that is
most important
and it ties to what we were talking
about before
um is really about
this being really really clear on the
critical priorities
because you know your time is so
valuable
you know you don't have a lot of
resources either people or money
so you've got to make sure you optimize
for those and i find too far off
too far in many cases that
entrepreneurs you know they're just
trying to do too much
and just declare for yourself what those
are
and focus on those and try not to get
sucked into all the noise around you
because there's going to be plenty of it
and think about what those critical
things are for your business
wonderful raymond thank you so much for
your time today it's so generous of you
but before we leave i need
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh with explanation or just the words
with them with a little explanation
would be wonderful okay uh
first and foremost family you know i
love spending time with my wife and kids
we travel a lot uh although not recently
and you know but we just like hanging
hanging out at home and you know kovitz
kind of brought even my kid
at college we're all here together and
really
uh the silver lining is all of it and
we're getting to spend some great time
together and we love spending time
together here up in tahoe and things
like that so that's why
secondly is just you know i guess
adaptable i've moved around a lot
uh i was born in south africa we moved
to israel when i was younger
and then ultimately made our way to the
united states and i came out to stanford
and
pretty much been put but you learn when
you're a young kid moving around a lot
you you just learn you got to figure out
how to survive and
adapt and fit in and you know make a go
of things
i can definitely yeah and then finally
uh iron man i've done iron man
triathlons and uh
iron man uh multiple full ironmans
so we should have talked about this the
whole time not not entrepreneurship
this is the most interesting wow well
okay well let's set up a follow-up on
this
but um i'm dealing with some injuries
now so i'm not sure if they're any
future iron man's but
uh you know it was a great mental
challenge and physical one obviously and
so yeah those are the three things
i was registered for a half iron man
about three days before
covet really took over and it was up in
napa valley
and so i'm definitely way out of shape
now so
i'm using that as an excuse to say that
if it would have happened i would have
done it now i don't feel like i have to
do it
but was that the one in santa rosa
i think it was it's called the napa
valley
so hopefully next year yeah definitely
definitely do it it'll you'll
discover it's life-changing i'm sure no
no i'm sure
raymond thank you very very much we
didn't even talk about j ventures but i
want to thank you for for being so
inspiring and teaching through that as
well so
so thank you for your help over there
and thank you for your time and best of
luck through this
crazy crazy time my pleasure lee thought